[Music]
with any remaining passengers for flight
ka29 please make their way to gate B15
good morning everyone this is Captain
Robin Allen speaking flight on today is
6 hours 54 minutes
[Music]
operation has commenced phones tablets
line is under control
[Music]
you need to see this Plainfield of
course
someone is calling for help
got family loved ones I warned you up to
do right now just improve to them I got
a message from the plane that says
incident on board
what exactly does your dad do for a
living it's difficult to explain Sam's
the best at handling it online
the negotiation
there are 200 people on this flight
if they try something and then this
plane goes down I don't get home to my
family
let me make you an offer
I've been handed demands it's all going
wrong in the first hour imagine a next
six we need to get a message to the
whole plane
we need to be ready
there's other stuff going down five
passengers on that plane do not exist
it's a network running all across Europe
so then we're an incoming missile
all done
I tell you it's not gonna be us
[Music]